Once Upon a Time HTC was one of the
biggest smartphone producers in the
entire world in fact in 2011 they were
the third largest phone manufacturer in
the entire world only beaten out by
Apple and Samsung themselves within the
US HTC was even ahead of Samsung as the
go-to Android phone maker with a market
share of
24% but ever since then it's only been
straight down for HTC in fact you now
need two leading zeros to describe their
global market share of just
0.09% even the revived Nokia brand has
five times the market share within Just
4 years HTC's Revenue dropped from $6
billion to less than $2 billion and
their net income well that went from
barely being profitable to heavily being
in the red losing hundreds of millions
of dollars every single year HTC would
eventually end up selling a large
portion of themselves to Google out of
desperation but this too hasn't LED any
anywhere things are so bad that rumors
about HTC shutting down their smartphone
business altogether have been flying
around for years now it's easy to write
off this massive decline as just a
result of Apple and Samsung dominating
the market and becoming a duopoly but
there's a lot more to the story you see
much of HTC's decline can be explained
by HTC's own decisions but not in the
way that you might think with a company
like Yahoo or Xerox for example their
leadership simply made the wrong choice
Al together with HTC though their
leadership often actually made the right
choices but the competition simply made
even better choices in fact during the
early part of their decline HTC was
actually putting up record numbers year
after year it's just that the
competition was putting up even more
impressive record numbers so it's not
necessarily that HTC went down but
rather that they simply couldn't keep up
the smartphone industry simply continued
to explode without them and over time
this destroyed them from the outside in
so join me as we take a look back at the
Monstrous rise and fall of one of the OG
smartphone producers
HTC taking a look back the story of HTC
can be traced all the way back to May
15th 1997 to Taiwan a full decade ahead
of the iPhone the name HTC Corporation
actually stands for High-Tech computer
Corporation and H TC definitely tried to
live up to this name in fact most of
their efforts over the years went into
trying to innovate and create the next
big thing for example in 1998 they would
begin designing one of the world's first
touchscreen smartphones and they weren't
just trying to make a smarter mobile
phone either the real goal was to make a
full-fledged handheld computer that ran
windows and they would succeed too in
2002 they would launch the world's first
Windows powered smartphone but not only
did HTC launch the world's first Windows
smartphones but they would go on to
launch the world's first Android
smartphone the T-Mobile G1 also known as
the HTC dream HTC wasn't just innovating
with smartphones either they were very
much pushing forward the entire mobile
industry in 2005 they helped popularize
3G and just a few years later they would
help popularize 4G with the launch of
America's first 4G phone the HTC Evo 4G
hearing all this I don't think you'd be
surprised to hear that HTC was named as
one of the most Innovative companies in
the world in 2010 as a modern tech
company in a rapidly evolving and highly
competitive industry such as smartphones
you would think that this is precisely
the mindset that you would need the
mindset to constantly innovate and push
forward after all isn't that what Apple
did well not exactly you see Apple's
real Innovations were not in technology
itself with the most smartphone
Technologies Android usually does it
first and it's not till years later that
Apple does the same thing
but it's completely different when Apple
does it because Apple's real Innovation
is often not in the technology itself
but actually in how the technology is
delivered for example how Apple made
face ID so reliable that you could
seamlessly use it dozens of times every
day and not even notice how they made
bite-sized Bluetooth headphones that not
only provided a strong listening
experience but also practical battery
life how they make it a breeze to take
professional level pictures and videos
Apple's real Innovative power is not in
creating new technologies but rather
taking existing Technologies and making
them effortless HTC on the other hand
was truly just working on creating new
technologies for example the HTC EVO 3D
was the first phone to leverage door
rear cameras something that was copied
by Apple and everyone else similarly the
HTC Thunderbolt was the first LT enabled
phone years before apple and everyone
else and the HTC M7 was the first
aluminum unibody phone something that
was oddly familiar to the iPhone 6 but
while these Innovations may have spoken
to Tech enthusiasts the same cannot be
said about the general public when it
came to the general public apple and
Samsung's approach of packaging
Technologies and innovating experiences
was simply far more effective but as we
know Apple themselves wasn't able to
keep up with this forever eventually
they did start dropping the ball the
iPhone 15 for example is likely their
most uninspiring launch of all time but
none of this is really hurting Apple
because they Diversified it's not that
HTC didn't try diversifying themselves
but let's just say it didn't go nearly
as well for
them iPhone sales have been declining
for years now in fact Apple doesn't even
want to reveal how many units they're
moving nowadays but this hasn't hurt
their bottom line at all because they've
been able to diversify instead of
monetizing the sale of iPhones Apple has
moved towards monetizing other parts of
the smartphone business like the use of
the iPhone similarly Samsung has seen a
lot of success as a background player
within the smartphone industry most
people know Samsung for their Galaxy and
note phones but Samsung is actually one
of the biggest background players within
the smartphone industry dominating the
display and flash memory markets in fact
iPhone screens themselves are made by
Samsung so clearly there's a lot of
money to be made through strategic
diversification and HTC knew it in fact
they've been trying to do similar
diversification efforts for over a
decade now but it hasn't quite played
out the same way for example in 2011
they decided to increase their control
over the hardware Space by purchasing S3
graphics for $300 million S3 Graphics
had made strides within the 3D industry
and held hundreds of critical patents
that had been licensed out to Sony
Nintendo and Microsoft for their gaming
consoles so HDC figured that they could
take over S3 graphics and to become a
licensing giant within the smartphone
Graphics industry Google was making a
similar play around the same time with
Motorola they spent 12 and a half
billion dollar to acquire Motorola and
more specifically there are 14,600
patents and they would use these patents
to successfully defend themselves
against Apple's lawsuits against Android
making the acquisition a massive success
HTC was likely hoping that they could
pull off a similar Victory against Apple
but unfortunately for them the court
would end up siding with apple and S3
would just end up Fading Into Oblivion
after that fortunately HTC was working
on other diversification efforts as well
like Beats by Dre years before Apple got
involved HTC invested $300 million into
beats in 2011 and acquired a majority
stake in the company but as HTC's
fundamentals started declining they
decided to cash in on this investment
prematurely selling for a mere $56
million Profit just one year after this
apple would end up buying Beats for $3
billion talk about about bad timing from
HTC obviously HTC did not have much luck
with the music industry but one industry
where they were not only early but stuck
around to the end was streaming HDC
actually made it two separate streaming
related Investments the first of which
was a game streaming company called
OnLive OnLive was basically an early
version of Google stadia and it already
had big players backing them including
BT Warner Brothers and AT&T like Google
stadia though on live didn't end up
working out and they would end end up
shutting down in early 2015 fortunately
HTC's other streaming related
acquisition was going much better
saffron digital saffron digital
specialized in creating and hosting the
infrastructure used by players like the
NBA NFL NHL Paramount NBC and Sony but
after getting stung by OnLive HDC would
decide to drisk when it came to
streaming and saffron would end up
getting acquired by new line honestly it
was probably a good idea to focus back
on their core product and start turning
things around but unfortunately this
turnaround never
came more than innovating the wrong
things and failing to diversify likely
the number one factor that dragged down
HTC was lackluster marketing and again
just like their Innovation and
diversification efforts it's not that
HTC was against Marketing in fact they
were all for marketing budgeting as much
as $1 billion for individual campaigns
they locked in A-list celebrities like
Robert Downey Jr paying him $12 million
for just a 2-minute commercial but while
HTC was on board with all of this I
think they made one fatal flaw which was
considering their brand positioning more
carefully it seems that HTC approached
the whole branding side of things a bit
too logically they basically thought
okay we have a solid set of products at
reasonable prices if we simply put this
in front of people with huge marketing
spend we should be selling out in no
time but but the reality is that
marketing Isn't So logical especially in
the Modern Age more and more people tend
to prioritize how a brand makes them
feel as opposed to what a brand is
offering them on paper this is precisely
why Apple's marketing is so effective
they're not selling the iPhone spec
sheet or its value proposition their
selling feelings the feeling of
premiumness with their material choices
and sliek Designs the feeling of
exclusivity with your high prices and
strategic Market positioning and most
importantly the feeling of inclusion
with imessage and FaceTime and now even
phone calls these feelings are what sell
the iPhones and galaxies not the spec
sheet and this is a massive departure
from how things used to be before 2000
as people usually just made purchase
decisions based on who could give them
the best bang for the buck that's why
companies like Sony and Panasonic were
so popular they made strong reliable
products for a reasonable price and
that's why people bought their products
as simple as that but trying to apply
this Legacy strategy to the smartphone
industry simply didn't work and I think
this is what really screwed over HTC on
all fronts in terms of innovation HDC
was looking to buff up the spec sheet
and pack in the best technology possible
when the real solution was to create the
best experience possible in terms of
diversification they stuck to
fundamentals S3 graphics for example
seem like a safe patent play and they
sold Off beats because they got a
reasonable offer there was no way to
expect that Apple would pay 3 billion
for Beats because it wasn't
fundamentally worth that much but Apple
was okay with paying that for
non-fundamental reasons and in terms of
marketing HDC was very much willing to
put their money where their mouth was
but their objective approach simply
didn't resonate with the general public
the reality was that HTC was always
trying to make the objectively right
choice but the truth is that it's often
the intangibles that make a company
truly successful and without those
intangibles HTC simply couldn't stand
the test of time with historically High
interest rates the appeal of bills and
bonds is higher than ever yet
traditional brokerages haven't really
adapted with the times they still expect
people to use clunky Bond tables scroll
through long overwhelming lists and even
use Virtual keyboards till recently and
that's why we created our own modern
Bond platform Silo at Silo we prioritize
the user experience and the ease of
finding an inv inting in the issuers you
know and trust so that you too can
easily lock in high yields also choosing
a strong user experience does not mean
sacrificing unsafety every Salo account
is insured by $500,000 in sipc insurance
and $2.5 million in FDIC Insurance also
all funds deposited on the platform will
be maintained by our trusted custodian
interactive brokers who has experienced
managing $373 billion worth of assets
over the past 45 years so if you're
looking for a modern way to invest in
bonds please consider checking out Silo
in the description below unlike HDC
Samsung actually ended up winning the
smartphone game but they're not doing
all that well anyway check out this
video to learn more but until then I'm
Hari and I'll see you guys on the next
one